das hier ist das erste von sieben
Interviews dass wir mit allen
Teilnehmern von Seven vs wild Staffel 2
produziert haben ab heute kommt in
täglichen Abstand jeden Tag ein weiteres
Interview wir starten heute mit Sascha
bei Staffel 2 hat sich einiges zu
Staffel 1 geändert hast du dich in
irgendeiner Weise auf diese Änderung
oder allgemein auf Server Strike
vorbereitet ich sag dir jetzt ich bin
gerade im buddhistenkloster ja für Video
komm da raus Handy abgegeben komm raus
Millionen Nachrichten du bist nominiert
Staffel 2 selber
nicht sowas ja nominiert das ist ja nix
zu bedeuten so nomina nominiert sind
vielleicht viele komme ich nach Hause
richtig die Community macht richtig
Stress heute was los wir wollen feedback
so ich habe mir eine Woche Zeit gelassen
und wusste nicht ob ich mit dabei sein
soll weil auch bei der ersten Staffel
wurde ich angefragt und da habe ich mich
habe ich mir echt nicht zugetraut ich
hasse einfach nicht zugetraut und jetzt
würde ich halt öffentlich noch
jetzt aber natürlich entscheide ich
immer noch für mich egal ob jetzt Druck
oder kein Druck und habe mich dann dazu
entschlossen
mitzumachen und der Unterschied ich habe
mich vorbereitet habe mir versucht
vorzubereiten auch mit ja Kommando
Spezialeinheit Österreich Bundeswehr und
so Punkt ist aber du wirst von
Helikopter geschmissen landestar auf
irgendeinen Spot ich hatte im Kopf Sand
Palmen geil richtig weit geht's rein so
da kann ich richtig viel bauen und alles
ist Freifläche nichts da nur Steine
schneller Hand voll mit Stein und dann
ist oben der Müll und da hinten ist
einfach mal gerufenweise Wald aus keine
keine Option deswegen wieder rum gehst
oder irgendwas äh der anschaust oder
zumindest für mich nicht und das kannst
du dich nicht vorbereiten es ist einfach
next level und für mich einfach komplett
so Boom stimmt darüber wo bin ich da
jetzt verdammte Scheiße also wirklich
ausgemalt aber wenn das dann rauskommt
dabei dann ist einfach nur ein Schock ja
du hast gerade gesagt du hast es Dir
etwas anders vorgestellt eine Sache mit
der ihr bestimmt auch nicht gerechnet
habt war der etwas speziellere drop off
erzähl uns bitte wieder Drop auf Tag für
dich abgelaufen ist
Geschichte
was passiert so mitnehmen in der Nacht
ich kann nicht pennen ganz klar
Tropfen so pflanzliche damit ich
irgendwie runterkomme das so nervös mein
Herz geht die ganze bum bum höre ich um
4 Uhr morgens jemanden äh im Gang stehen
wenn sich knossi und Otto sehe ich Otto
in der Vollmond Tour schwarzes Gesicht
so Auto was machst du ja ich habe eine
Falle gebaut wenn sie uns aufwecken
kommen dann würden die so ein aluddose
entgegen geschossen bekommen aber die
sind nicht gekommen jetzt gehe ich die
suchen ja wo ist die ja Ja sagt ja ja
geh einfach versucht rauszufinden wo
dieses orgativ schläft was passiert dann
wir warten inzwischen Gang knosse nicht
dann kommt er zurück Alter [ __ ]
aha gerade bei irgendeinem älteren
Ehepaar angeklopft in seiner Vollmond
durch riesengroß schwarz angemalt und da
wollte sagen was ist jetzt los was sagt
das so sorry Rondorf geht er wieder weg
also ich glaube die sind an dem Tag
einfach vom Hotel wieder ausgecheckt und
kommt natürlich nichts mehr gepennt
einfach nur noch Fieber dann morgens
mein Frühstück knossi kommt her sagt
einfach Sascha was machen wir überall
die kameraske der einfach schnell am
frühstücken wir fahren gleich los und so
Sascha was machen wir müssen uns
gegenseitigen motivieren wenn man 10.000
€, wenn man das schaffen Schule keiner
was aber nur mit keiner aufgibt passt ja
ich sag einfach okay so ich denke mal
nichts dabei noch nie in meinem Leben so
eine Summe irgendwie Geräte irgend so
ein Scheiß plötzlich Scheiße überall
Kameras müsste jetzt ernst ja ja das ist
jetzt fix ja passt fix gut äh das noch
am morgen passiert ja und ähm dann sind
wir los und die Ankunft Helikopter war
für mich eigentlich ganz
krasse bemerkmal herum gefetzt aber ich
muss die ganze aufs Klo ich habe es echt
nicht ausgehalten das ist so ein
bisschen der ewig lang ja wie lange
waren wir denn in der Luft sicher
sicher 45 Minuten oder Stunde oder was
und ich habe natürlich davor extrem viel
getrunken damit ich dann ebenfalls kein
Süßwasserquelle gibt nichts was Wasser
braucht und die ganze Zeit so ich muss
aufs Klo aber ich war erst das letzte
Vorletzter dran und das war schief
gegangen runtergesprungen direkt alles
schön laufen lassen
zum Helikopterflug und zum frühen Morgen
danach ja oder morgen davor was war dann
dein erstes Gefühl als du die Helis
gesehen hast geil ich dachte mir
hoffentlich daher nicht das Brot ich
dachte mir einfach so ein Staat was
gibt's geileres du springst da vom Heli
fester ins Wasser rein es macht mal
einen Knall so richtig rum du gehst mal
vier Meter unter gehst wieder gefühlt
gehst wieder auf der doch wieder auf und
denkst einfach jetzt geht's los mit was
für einen Kanal kann sowas bitte noch
heftiger starten nur so und du weißt
Helikopter fliegt weg und es ist ganz
alleine also das ist so ein Moment hat
richtig geprägt war krass okay Job also
mit positiven Gefühlen rein gestartet
wie hat sich das dann aber in Richtung
vom Tag 3 geändert als das Wetter immer
schlechter wurde ja also es war so ich
bin angekommen und dachte mir erst mal
coole Challenge startet jetzt endlich im
Moment der lang Wochen lang darauf
vorbereitet endlich geht es mal los so
aber dann
schon gecheckt bei mir sind nur Felsen
alles ist anders was mache ich da
und dann hat sich ja noch meine spontane
kann man sich schon sagen ja ja wenn
meine spontane Idee da meine Sachen noch
einzugraben dachte ich habe Zahnstocher
gar nicht alles schön ein und so aber
war nur Steine wo ich sie reingelegt
habe ganz oben habe ich versucht da
einzugraben hat die eingegraben aber
einfach gedacht scheiß drauf ich muss
jetzt mein Plan durchziehen ich habe dem
organteam nur Bescheid geben auch nicht
den Teilnehmern weil ich nicht wollte
dass die dann Druck haben und so und ich
wollte auch keinen Druck machen ich will
einfach nur ich will auch nicht
vergleichen ich will ja für mich das
wollte für mich das machen und ja die
meinten halt ich habe gesagt hey lass
mich mit einem Gegenstand gehen oder
halt verbunden die anderen und diese
nachmachen oder nicht wenn du das machst
das Risiko musst selbst tragen und
selbst vergraben und dann viel Spaß und
so ja das wird nicht richtig jetzt noch
nie im Leben sowas gemacht ich komme von
der Fitness-Szene und nicht hier auf ja
dann gemacht und dann dachte ich mir war
das jetzt eine gute Idee ich habe
versucht ein Seil aufzuhängen die
durchgebrochen es Hängematte habe ich
nur noch eine Möglichkeit gehabt und das
war bei mir
habe natürlich noch nicht damit
gerechnet dass die Fluter kommen wird
nach drei Tagen wie du sagst da ein zwei
drei Tage Vollmond irgendwann immer
näher jede Nacht ja dann bin ich fast
jede Nacht der gestanden stundenlang
neben meinem Shelter weil ich musste da
raus weil ich wusste es kann jeden
Moment zusammenbrechen und dann gehe ich
da unter oder oder bleibt stecken oder
das war richtig schwer und groß und das
dann das Gewitter kam das erste war
irgendwie nice zu erleben so mal anders
aber am zweiten beim dritten das nie
aufgehört hat richtig Angst bekommt
Machete Weg ja damit der blitzt dann
nicht irgendwie rein fährt hockst du da
irgendwo weiß die Krokodile sind da am
Boden vier Stunden also da ging es dann
los wo ich wirklich so gemerkt habe so
was habe ich da eingelassen dass sie
wirklich auch eine rationale Gefahr also
das ist ja nicht so oder kann der keine
versichern dass der Blitz nicht trifft
oder die Krokodile fressen und da dachte
ich mir jetzt extrem mulmiges Gefühl und
die Isolation hat bei mir relativ
schnell gekickt er muss schon sehr sagen
also wie sehr mir Menschen abgehen das
hätte ich mir nicht gedacht zumindest
die Menschen im engen
so wie wie schwer mir das Feld allein zu
sein einfach einfach komplett also ich
habe es geschafft ja also es ging
aber war schon heftig und da wie du
sagst nach paar Tagen da war das jeden
Tag Thema irgendwie abzulenken du
stellst dir irgendwie Gedanken versinkst
Lieder irgendwas singst du da völlig hin
längst dich irgendwie absolut geht okay
krass war das dann auch so dein größtes
Problem und wenn nicht was war dein
größtes Problem mein absolut größtes
Problem war die Isolation definitiv ich
hatte Süßwasser nichts zu essen
scheißegal im Vergleich Moskitos zwar
scheiße die Steine immer umgeknickt ich
hatte mir nur er hat leider keine Schuhe
die Knöchel also Knöchel hoch ja nicht
darüber er hat nichts stabilisiert also
ständige Schmerzen Fußsohlen Daten die
ganze Zeit weh
kleinste Schnitte Stiche überall an den
Armen sowieso aber im Vergleich zu dem
allen Durchfall ja alles volle Programm
Übelkeit Schwindel aber das alles
ist zu dem Gefühl dass du isoliert bist
und weißt wenn ich das passiert kann ich
nicht sofort irgendwer retten und die
Gefahr auch wenn sie vielleicht nicht so
hoch ist weiß nicht so viele Krokodile
gibt alle anderen Teilnehmer zwei
Teilnehmer haben also so wenige gibt
anscheinend nicht
ist einfach trotzdem dass die Isolation
und das war für mich das hat mich
innerlich zerfressen so jeden Tag habe
ich ja glaube ich auch sehr
philosophische Worte an an die Zuschauer
gerichtet einfach versucht das alles
rauszulassen mit der Kamera zu reden
authentisch auch zu sein und nicht auch
Schwächen zu lassen nicht zu sagen nur
weil es mir jetzt richtig schlecht geht
für mich das einfach nicht mir geht's
auch wieder gut gibt ja auch gute Phasen
und dann fühle mich nur das ja Nein
bewusst mache ich so dass ich auch die
Phasen mitnehmen wo ich nicht gut geht
weil ähm ich glaube
für alle die sowas noch nie gemacht
haben der wird wahrscheinlich den
meisten genau gleich gehen ja wenn ich
so vielleicht sogar noch schlimmer ja
weil mit nur ein Gegenstand 7 Tage
durchziehen oder sowas noch nie gemacht
hat ist war ich kein Zuckerschlecken und
von dem her war mir wichtig dass auch zu
in die Message einzupacken Isolation ist
hart für uns Menschen und diese Gruppe
dürfen sie wieder zu erleben einfach
dass das fehlt essen gehen geiles Essen
im Kühlschrank nimmst den Käse raus und
was trinken Wasserhahn Freundin du
liegst im Bett warten Insektenschutz und
scheißen sektenschutz an einem Fenster
was der für ein Wert hat oder ein Dach
seit kannst auch scheiß Dach sein kaputt
sein solange es trocken ist irgendwie
und du hast es ist doch ein Luxus was
wir haben doch ein Luxus die Möbel will
hauen uns auf die Couch riesengroß Basch
liegst du da drauf und all das war
einfach du hockst nur kurz wie ohne Ende
aber das alles drin ist so aus wenn
andere weil die Emotionalität einfach
viel krasser wirkt als die körperlichen
Schmerzen
bei mir okay heftig wir hoffen du
hattest aber nicht nur Schwierigkeiten
und negative Gedanken was ist etwas
Positives dass du aus dieser Zeit für
dich mitnimmst boah ist jetzt echt so
gute Frage also auf alle Fälle weil die
eine Kokosnuss die richtig leckeres
Kokoswasser drin hatte die war richtig
das waren so ein geiler Moment einfach
dann als ich mein Shelter das zweite
Shelter nachdem das erste nicht geklappt
hat das zweite dann aber halbwegs
geklappt hat dachte mir cool wenigstens
liege ich erhöht relativ hoch fühle mich
safe cooles Gefühl
dann warst du noch ein cooles Gefühl
da wird schon schwer ja ich sag mal so
ich glaube dieses coole Gefühl dieses
das hast du im Nachhinein ja wenn im
Nachhinein reduzierst ich habe es
geschafft und ich habe jetzt für mein
Leben was dazugelernt was mir keiner
mehr nehmen kann was mich vielleicht
auch ein Stück persönlich Charakter den
Charakter weiterentwickelt ja das glaube
ich ist so und das ganze Leben einfach
mitnehmen dass man mit wenigen Dingen
glücklich sein kann das machen wir jetzt
richtige nachher richtig glücklich so
dass ich das Leben hat dürfen dieses
ganze nichts zu haben ist richtig
dagegen kann wie gut uns eigentlich geht
und das glaube ich ist der wahre Werte
von mir zumindest gewesen hier damit zu
machen um einfach wieder ja mal wieder
back to the roots wie ist es eigentlich
da draußen in der Natur nicht immer nur
in unserem Betonkern und das war der
Hardcore positiv Defekt bei mir aber
ansonsten Kokosnuss und wenn eine
Challenge halbwegs geklappt hat was
nicht so auf der Fahrer bei mir muss ich
sagen ja das ist einmal rauskommt das
auch ganz normal
geil Stachelrochen siehst du jeden Abend
vorbeischauen zu viert denkst aber das
sind auch sozial und so zu 14 Sie
unterwegs sind cool so so Moment da gab
es schon auch ja aber die meiste Zeit
war natürlich einfach survival Überleben
im Endeffekt hast du es dir ja auch
durch das Eingraben deiner Gegenstände
schwerer gemacht als es eigentlich für
dich angedacht war würdest du dich
wieder dazu entscheiden deine
Gegenstände einzubuddeln und wenn du dir
in der Mitte der Woche einen Gegenstand
wieder hättest dabei wünschen können
welcher wäre es gewesen erste auf alle
Fälle ja
mich pusht einfach die Challenge ich
brauche das aber wenn ich weiß bekomm 5
Gegenstände voll mein sieben dann haben
die gesagt fünf weil für die Außenseiter
von den ganzen Welt in die haben den
Ding geben mir dann dachte ich mir okay
ich gebe mir zwei weg dann nimmt mir
noch alle weg also bis auf die Machete
scheiß drauf die Challenge die brauche
ich die liebe ich und die motiviert mich
halt auch und da geht's nicht darum zu
beweisen jetzt schaue ich ganz mit einer
mit ein Gegenstand schaffen sondern
geht's einfach darum mich selbst zu
motivieren schaut das nur ein Gegenstand
das ist unser motiviert da wenn es
regnet scheiß drauf ein Gegenstand du
hast ja ausgesucht nun kann Retro sagt
man es gibt kein Zurück ja und deswegen
auf alle Fälle ja
und ähm ich hätte sonst sofort die
Hängematte genommen sofort die
Hängematte bisschen tiefer reingehen
keine Angst mehr vor der Flut jeden Tag
wusste Vorstellung 2 Uhr nachts nicht
einpennen das erste nicht einpennen
können weil du nicht weißt da und wann
ist es soweit dass die dagegen Brecht
kannst du sagen ja da wäre ich im Mund
aber was falls nicht zu gefährlich
kannst du fast nicht einpennen und dann
mehrere Stunden neben dem Shelter zu
stehen und zuschauen wie du ihn Regen
stehst und dein cheter kaputt wird ist
natürlich mental der Horror und äh ja
dachte mir einfach jetzt Hängematte
aufspannen
genügend da am Strand ja einfach
aufspannen liege ich da drin alles ist
easy die Welt ist gut die Welt ist schön
und wenn es dann noch ein Moskitonetz
hast und eine Tat also wenn jemand sagt
er will in Dschungel oder auf tropische
Inseln einfach mal nicht so krass aber
doch auch krass ein bisschen
expeditionsmäßig dann unbedingt Pflicht
Hängematte muss integrierten Moskitonetz
damit
dabei ist und du hast Geister leben oder
halt zumindest nicht so schwer ist aber
was mich als nächstes interessiert hast
du in der Woche ernsthaft überlegt den
Knopf zu drücken und dich abholen zu
lassen ja also nein richtig abbrechen
ich hatte echt auch scheiß Gefühle und
alles war da und so [ __ ] aber richtig
dass du gedacht habe was soll ich jetzt
wirklich aufgeben dann werden die jetzt
dann da und soll ich jetzt wirklich
machen durchs nicht so das gab's nicht
sogar in der Früh wenn du den cocaine
oder oder Marvins schicken musstest
immer doppelt runter drücken
ich sehe ausgewählt ja Gott sei Dank so
ist ihr der Gedanke gewesen ähm was aber
nicht das ganze jetzt was nicht heißen
soll das für mich einfach war ganz und
gar nicht aber aufzugeben war keine
Option dann bist Du hier wartest du
einfach ja es bringt alles nichts scheiß
drauf und ähm wenn ich aufgeben hätte
wäre wenn bei mir ganz ehrlich wenn ich
vielleicht ein Krokodil gesehen habe ich
weiß halt dass du Krokodil Leben hier
und die sind die fressen Menschen das
ist einfach [ __ ] den kann man nicht
schön reden es ist einfach so auch wenn
es hier vielleicht nicht oft passiert
und allein ist dass ich da schlafen weil
war ja auch noch dann deren
Süßwasserquelle ist leicht und ich
schlaf danach und die Fresse mich
einfach und ich habe keine Ahnung und
ich weiß er lebt genau da eins wo ich
bin da werden einfach die rationale
Gefahr zu hoch gewesen mein Leben
einfach zu
ich bin gerne am Leben was soll ich
sagen ich bin gerne am leben ich lebe
einfach gern und das ist mir einfach
nicht wert dann deswegen auch wenn es
nicht so eine Gefahr zu sterben und mein
Shelter wenn das wirklich komplett
zusammengebrochen wäre
wenn es am Anfang passiert wäre dann
mehr hätte ich vielleicht noch ein
zweites geworden als am Anfang war ich
nicht gleich aufgegeben wenn es am
Schluss passiert wäre gut dann hätte ich
vielleicht auch noch woanders gepennt
weil ich weiß weil ich war zu Schluss da
ja aber das wäre gewesen aber ja
Hauptsache die zwei Dinge ja weil der
Grund gewesen oder hat eine richtig
heftige Verletzung aber ich hatte ja
Übelkeit Schwindelanfälle Durchfall
komplett und da einfach da musst du
durch da musst du durch oder mit dem
Daumen geschnitten und so aber das durch
durch Hammer die letzte und vermutlich
wichtigste Frage was ist dein Fazit der
Woche und würdest du deinen besten
Freundin empfehlen so eine Erfahrung mal
selber zu machen
im Nachhinein ist die Erfahrung jedem zu
wünschen auf dieser Welt jedem
die Frage ist nur willst du es auch
jemanden empfehlen wo du eigentlich so
jetzt die denkst
kann ist das was für dich wenn es für
den nix ist dann hat er nur negative
Aspekte und gibt sofort auf dann bist du
extra weiten Weg her geflogen als ich
vorbereitet bis paar Stunden da und sag
musst wieder weg und muss dann eine
Woche da warten dann was doch was doch
nicht schön ist aber wenn du willst der
könnte das paar Tage durchstehen so und
auch wenn so ein paar Tage sind dann
würde ich jeden empfehlen zu machen weil
jeder Tag den du verbracht hast allein
dort auf dieser Insel ohne Handy ohne
Social Media ohne Menschen ist hart aber
er lehrt dich halt sehr viel und zeigte
welche Menschheit wirklich bist und ich
glaube er hat mich auch echt zum Guten
besseren Menschen gemacht ganz ehrlich
ich glaube wirklich dass mir die diese
Erfahrung zu einem besseren Menschen
gemacht hat weil ich habe echt dann auch
so überlegt ja was ist wichtig du musst
im Leben was hilft wirklich
Freundschaften auch pflegen ja nicht
immer das vernachlässigt man vielleicht
mal schnell mal eine Freundin oder mal
ähm einen Job oder so keine Ahnung auch
Beziehungen gehören gepflegt und dieses
soziale das gehört wirklich gepflegt und
ich sag's dir da habe ich so gedacht
ich muss einfach auf mir
Prioritätenliste machen wo so Dinge wie
Zeit mit Freunden verbringen
zurückzugeben sei es irgendwelche Dinge
mal was Gutes zu tun irgendwie irgendwas
das hat wirklich auch
öfter zu machen weil das macht die
eigentlich glücklich am Ende des Tages
es klingt jetzt so pauschal und so was
man immer hört bei jeder Scheiß Floskel
steht auf jeden Badezimmerwand aber am
Ende des Tages ist echt so wenn du was
gibst und und einfach Freunde hast auf
die du zehn kannst oder Familie und
Freundin und sie auf dich weil du auch
weißt ich bin für euch da kostet etwas
Wolle ist doch schön das ist doch
wirklich das hatten Wert alles andere
was ist ein Auto im Vergleich
weg und am Ende des Tages sind die
kleinen Dinge die zählen und ja habe
mich verdammt glücklich gemacht die
Erfahrung und hoffentlich auch dafür
mich besser überzeugt zu einem besseren
Menschen ich glaube uns alle diese
Einsamkeit zu spüren zu überlegen zu
reflektieren Menschen alle viel mehr
anstatt einfach zu sagen ja dass sie
schlecht total schlecht aber wie sieht's
bei dir aus und diese Reflexion auch
zuzulassen auch mal Schwächen zu
erkennen es kostet echt viel Energie und
viel Zeit zu tief zu grübeln wo du
denkst ja eigentlich ist doch dieser
Kaktus und dann denkst du aber denk mal
noch mal nach und nochmal nach okay okay
was könnte ich ändern an dir selbst und
das halt schon das braucht viel glaube
ich auch Disziplinen Mut da sich das zu
trauen den eigenen Schwächen zu erkennen
die zu reflektieren und dann zu
verbessern und vor allem mal zu erkennen
und dann aber auch umzusetzen wow was
für schöne Schlussworte herzlichen
Glückwunsch als einer der Personen die
die sieben Tage durchgestanden hat und
viel Spaß zurück in der Zivilisation
danke schön ey danke mach es gut geht
[Musik]